je suis nominé comme meilleur comédien
et meilleure série mais enfin ça c'est
pas ces courses et commissaire moulin
connais pas ça passe sur les écrans
c'est pas ça scandaleux que vous ne
soyez jamais nominé a chuté de 32,2
exposé préparer un rictus de convenance
si vous n'avez pas quand la caméra soit
sur vous non non non non vous avez
oublié votre mieux ce soir
oui oui mais il est dans ma poche moussa
je sors du boulou l'attention liste
disons que certainement si on regardait
un petit peu quels seront les nominés
sur zeller thème ils auront sûrement
très bon jupiter alors dans ce cas là on
pourrait peut-être imaginer que les
vierges de satan favoriser et puis et
puis aussi les caprices tombe
comment ça retombe dans la sueur le j
entends pense que vous avez quand même
tout pompé sur les inconnus vous trouvez
pas c'est un petit peu scandaleux d'être
nominé à chaque fois bah ouais la loi de
la jungle on vole beaucoup et puis voilà
vous êtes encore nominé cette année
alors que vous avez tout pompé sur les
nuls ou retrouver passer un petit peu
scandaleux mais disons qu'on est
vraiment on n'est pas très intelligent
on n'est pas des bons comédiens on s'est
dit on va essayer d'aller au plus facile
voilà pour essayer de pomper sur des
mecs du talent dans la série que sont
ils devenus
ce soir julie c'est agréable invité à
l'économie mais bien vite et déjà c'est
étonnant je suis ravi des trois puits
situé avec quelqu'un si je prends pas de
jacou lancé soir chacun sa merde on veut
un plan pour le fourguer déjà mais j'ai
déjà refourguer sud il ya trois ans
j'ai un copain qui les fait fondre et
qu'il est qui ont fait des compressions
pour ses charges
bon je vais l'offrir comme les deux
précédents et ça va te faire marrer je
vais l'offrir à ma mère je traduis rire
parce que ça m'a pas fait marrer est ce
que comme beaucoup de personnes ce soir
vous êtes emmerder copieux après l'une
de l'autre on n'avait jacasser la classe
et ça te laves comment et qu'est-ce que
tu as comme lessive et patati et patata
c'est rob etc
ab alors christine vient ici le dire je
connais mieux que moi parce que regarder
quand même ça s'emballe et c'est toi qui
a voulu être payé penser que ce soit on
a touché le fond une question est vite
vous avez la calypso qui est garée en
double file
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus